protects the spare room subsidy and Lord
reform were all big news yesterday or
were they well significant announcements
in those particular areas and many
others were published by the government
but you might not have actually heard
about them and that's not because we
weren't doing our job a little
correspondent so peerage is here to tell
us more about this sophie is this just
very keen civil servants and government
istres clearing their desks ahead of
christmas or there's something else
going on here there's something else
going on it's known as take out the
trash day which is effectively when the
government desires to dump all it's bad
news at the same time and the hope is
that people don't look too closely at
what's at the bottom of some of those
bin bags so just to sort of show you the
last day of the parliamentary year it
has been traditionally used to very bad
news under heaps of other more mundane
end-of-year announcements a 17th take
out they're not fresh day of meant that
not justice government it's used in the
UK also the US are known to do this as
well now these are the 424 reports
statements data releases that were all
released simultaneously just in time for
mps to head back there constituency's
for christmas and you've read through
one of them of course you have a bit
more course yes absolutely yeah all 424
of them but we can definitely take a
look at some of them in more detail so
here the Department for Work and
Pensions now this is this spare room
subsidy report into the so-called
bedroom tax that was carried out by the
independent research organization tips
us more-- along with the cambridge scent
of housing and planning research so what
it found was that more than three
quarters are those people affected by
the changes to the bedroom tax all
sparing subsidies had they had to cut
down on food as a result of the policy
now you can see why you want to bury
that exactly another one here the fries
in council tax that has been scrapped
again bit of bad news coming from the
department for local government there
and what happened here is after four
years of promises to fruit to freeze
council taxes they decided to scrap that
funding scheme some council say that
they could lose out as a result now on
to the Home Office are just moving on to
the home office here
they buried some very controversial was
very controversial one exactly now
they've said that 30,000 failed asylum
seekers could be still in the United
Kingdom in this country after losing
their right to appeal so perhaps as a
example then that they're losing track
over the figures 10,000 current asylum
seekers that could be can't be tracked
by the Home Office so very controversial
one there and then just finally to show
you this one too controversial plans for
the house of laws to lose the power to
block certain legislation David Cameron
proposed the House of Commons should
have the final say laws after the Lord's
blocked previous plans to cut tax
credits so several months after the
election they also said that they were
going to publish the list of special
advisers as well for the further home
that later I mentioned said he cut down
on he did he said he was going to cut
the cost of government actually it's
gone up the number of special advisers
and the cost of them crucially which is
paid for of course by the taxpayer 1.2
million pounds in 2050 see why the
government's hoping perhaps that then
please go away have their turkey and
forget all about exactly that too
probably not Sophie thanks so Mikey